you know I like Joe Biden and I like his
awkwardness and some of his bizarre
comments but he did something now that a
lot of right-wingers are tying into the
Hillary is sick conspiracy theories uh
yesterday or the day before I believe it
was yesterday Joe Biden showed up in
Pennsylvania to join Hillary Clinton for
a rally there and he comes down off of
his airplane and goes to hug Hillary
Clinton and as will play for you here as
I describe what's going on he did what
many people are describing is way too
long of an embrace where he kept his
hands sort of around Hillary Clinton's
back and and waist and she does the Pat
which sort of as a signal that we are
now ending the hug and he seems to
almost polar in closer she does seem
somewhat kind of like she's hanging
there in his arms and like she really
really really wants to end this hug and
Republicans have come up with the idea
that Biden sense that Hillary because
she's very very sick as we're hearing
from some right-wingers that he had to
hold her up to prevent her from falling
on the ground in some kind of pancaked
uh mess uh and to me it just seems like
this is joe biden being joe biden where
he wanted to hug Hillary for 18 seconds
and that's what he was going to do no
matter how many seconds Hillary wanted
to be hugged yeah just YouTube uh Joe
Biden awkward moment yeah you'll get a
plethora of great material he's kind of
an awkward guy and he has these moments
out i think it was way more awkward by
the way when he was rubbing the
shoulders of Secretary of Defense ash
Carter wife and we'll play that for you
as I sort of remind you of that incident
and he just goes up behind her and start
squeezing her shoulders she has a look
on her face like what on earth is
happening behind me and he just stays
right there he is not moving he is
keeping those hands on her shoulders and
that is what is going on and then of
course one of my favorite Biden moments
of all time referencing President
Obama's big stick take a look at this
one now is the time to heed the timeless
advice from Teddy Roosevelt speak softly
and carry a big stick end of quote I
promise you the president has
big stick I promise take it from Joe
Biden President Obama stick is not small
and that he clearly communicated clearly
to us I really like Joe Biden I think
he's a very very good debater I still
remember when he made mincemeat out of
Paul Ryan during that vice presidential
debate in twenty twelve uh these moments
I find absolutely hilarious they really
say very nothing about Joe Biden's
political prowess which is uh pretty
he's carrying the biggest stick of all
when it comes to that isn't it yeah Joe
Biden's got a huge one and it's uh he's
just a character he's a character and uh
it would have been interesting to see
him run but of course he's not going to
oppose Hillary he's uh guess you could
say an establishment candidate Jason do
you you like this type of thing I mean
doesn't influence my opinion I feel like
Joe Biden must gone for a really tight
hug with Obama one point got a little
extra you know three in there yeah I
think he's just a guy who is really all
about uh he just likes people you know
and he's embraces people and how could
any of us criticize him for that